bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
comme chaque semaine nous sommes au
parlement européen à bruxelles et dans
cette émission nous nous demandons si
l'europe n'est pas en train de se
désagréger les italiens ont envoyé un
message anti système et anti austérité à
bruxelles et nous partirons également en
reportage à londres où 60 % des
britanniques veulent quitter l'europe
mais l'actualité c'est aussi la
commission européenne qui baisse ses
prévisions de croissance pour la france
et les chiffres ne sont pas bons pour le
reste de l'europe alors cette question
le vieux continent se dirige-t-il vers
le déclin on les attendait ces chiffres
la commission européenne a publié ses
prévisions de croissance pour les 27 de
l'union européenne c'est pas vrai s'est
même catastrophique pour certains
plaignent de la zone euro
c'est finalement une croissance de 0,1
pour sow pas plus ce qui est prévu pour
la france en 2013 il y a ceux qui sont
pessimistes avec cette croissance quasi
nulle
l'objectif du déficit public à 3 % c'est
impossible à atteindre
et il ya ceux qui sont optimistes si je
suis conscient qu'en matière de
croissance
ce sont les chiffres de la commission
pour 2013 notre vision immédiat reste
difficile mais je veux le dire aussi aux
français l'espoir de la reprise se lève
l'espoir se lève mais la panne de
croissance concerne toute l'europe pour
le moment avec des pays plus durement
touchés que les autres par la crise la
grèce et l'espagne et leur taux de
chômage de 27%
l'hebdomadaire libéral the economist est
catégorique l'europe décline
l'europe est en train de perdre son
leadership économique et le journal de
prédire le classement pour 2022 des
puissances économiques dans le monde au
top les états unis devant la chine le
japon et l'inde le brésil à la sixième
place le premier pays européens
l'allemagne la france n'occupait plus
que la neuvième position de ce
classement contre la cinquième
actuellement dont l'hebdomadaire est
anglais donc pas forcément objectif en
ce qui concerne la france
mais quand même l'europe a désormais la
réputation d'être l'enfant à problèmes
de l'économie mondiale et se fait donner
la leçon par les capitalistes chinois ou
les économistes indien
de là à parler de déclin il y à un pas
que les plus optimistes ne veulent pas
franchir
alors l'ordre va vers le deck la vaste
question dominique riquet bonjour vous
êtes député européen membre du ppe parti
populaire européen vous est aussi vice
président de la commission des
transports et du tourisme alors est ce
que vous êtes optimiste ou pessimiste
sur l'europe est ce que l'europe leur
va-t-elle vers le déclin alors optimiste
parce que l'on s'engage pas dans
politique un politique européenne sur
n'est pas optimiste europe connaît une
crise est claire elle ne va pas vers le
déclin je pense qu'elle ce n est en
train de se relever le problème du repos
seront lavés dans le sujet 0,1 pour cent
de prévision de croissance pour la
france à tout chômage de 27% pour la
grèce et l'espagne est ce que la
politique de rigueur l'austérité c'est
la bonne solution
alors je pense que la difficulté tient
dans le fait qu'on doit arriver à un
équilibre entre le redressement des
comptes publics est nécessaire parce que
la maman de décider si la dette nous
étouffe
on peut pas continuer à fonctionner mais
il faut également et en même temps
préserver des marges de relance et la
capacité d'encourager la croissance soit
que celle équilibre entre les deux pieds
d'être difficile mais nous devons punir
d'accord on l'a dit vous faites partie
de la commission des budgets les 27 pays
de l'union européenne se sont accordés
sur un nouveau budget pour la période
2014 2020
ce budget pour la première fois il est
en baisse 1 c'est la première fois de
son histoire le l'europe peut leur peau
au pain sec et à l'eau
qu'est-ce que quel impact cette
politique d'austérité aura pour les pays
de l'union européenne
je pense c'est un très mauvais budget
pour beaucoup de raisons parce que on ne
peut pas considérer budget européen
comme le budget des états membres
parce que c'est un budget qui repart
d'ailleurs aux états membres qui est
essentiellement destiné à soutenir
la croissance donc c'est à la fois un
mauvais signal pour la croissance est un
mauvais signal pour l'europe parce que
l'europe a besoin d'avancer dans pas de
reculer et enfin je n'ai pas observé
d'ailleurs que les états mendy vie du et
leur budget à leur propre budget bien au
contraire puisque 24 heures une
injonction 27 ans encore
significativement augmenté leur budget
comme la france de 0.46 mais renseigne
mention bon donc c'est pas un bon budget
c'est pas un budget pour la croissance
je pense qu'il faudra discuter de ça
d'accord vous faites partie de la
commission des transports le budget pour
les infrastructures a été taillée ce que
vous allez le voter ce budget ou c'est
s'est levé tôt
le budget pour les infrastructures est
catastrophique puisqu'il a été dilué de
40 % par rapport à la production à la
proposition de la commission
or c'est un budget trois sens par
définition parce que faire des
infrastructures de transport de
télécommunication ou pour l'énergie
c'est préparer l'avenir préparer le
défis environnementaux et puis générer
de la croissance immédiatement et de la
compétitivité après c'était vraiment le
budget est 40%
franchement les députés européens ont le
pouvoir le parlement européen a le
pouvoir de l'accepter ou le rejeter en
bloc de ce budget ça va se passer en
juillet vous allez voter ou pas à moi
personnellement dans les tracts des
changes ne voterait pas ce budget comme
d'ailleurs bon nombre de mes collègues
j'ai été quatre principaux partis
--quatre président en fuite déclaration
pour dire qu'en l'état il n'était pas
recevable c'est pas avec un budget de
cette nature qu'on va faire avancer ni
l'europe
il a fait ressortir de son problème de
la raison principale c'est laquelle la
raison principale c'est que est ce que
pouvait donner à l'europe pour 2020 et à
budget qui est inférieur à celui de 2006
alors que nous avons des défis à relever
à d'élargissement des problèmes de
croissance a relancé
ça me paraît impossible on parle d'une
clause de révision en 2016 en cas de
retour à la croissance
ma grand mère elle disait cd prometteuse
bonjour c'est à dire sur on verra plus
tard
moi je pense que un budget acceptable
immédiat c'est mieux que la promesse
d'un budget qui sera peut-être
acceptable ultérieurement
je crois que c'est maintenant que les
gens ont besoin de poisson je pense que
le message des peuples européens il a
été clair les gens disent ça message
contre l'euro moi je pense que c'est
surtout un message contre des politiques
qui sont pas obligatoirement équilibré
il ya une chance de faire de la
croissance à travers le budget européen
il faut la prendre
l'actualité c'est aussi les élections
législatives britanniques s'est passé
une gifle à l'europe
ce résultat c'est surtout une gifle
système politique italien au premier
chef au deuxième chien aussi un vote de
défiance je crois en vers l'europe ou
plus exactement vers l'europe telle
qu'elle est perçue par les italiens à
travers leur propre classe politique est
là il ya un problème
moi je reviendrai pas sur le fait que
beppe grillo apparemment il avait un
métier de comics il fait 25% d'ivoire
d'italie ça se passe de commentaire
dominique heures et qui remercie d'avoir
accepté cette invitation donc l'autre
sujet d'actualité c'est bien évidemment
les élections législatives en italie est
un pays ingouvernable les télévisions
européennes en ont parlé
c'est le zapping
et là j'attends les résultats des
élections italienne devrait avoir des
conséquences sur les pays de la zone
euro à bruxelles
on craint que se voir préférer novembre
de l'intel gouvernable si la grande
préoccupation au sein de l'union
européenne les résultats sortis des
urnes en italie ils rendent le pays
difficile à gouverner
surtout à un moment où on a besoin de
stabilité pour affronter les défis
économiques
ce mot est compréhensible par tout le
monde a la une du journal
un bout vers nabeul l'italie en l'état
actuel des choses tout simplement parce
que les deux chambres sénat comme
chambre des députés ont strictement les
mêmes pouvoirs et que si le centre
gauche a une majorité absolue à la
chambre des députés
elle n'est que toute relative au sénat
et que beaucoup de ces projets de loi
bien nous ne passerons pas pour être
bloquée à tout moment situation délicate
en italie après les législatives les
résultats définitifs tarder à tomber
la gauche devrait s'imposer à la chambre
mais elle pourrait bien ne pas avoir la
majorité au sénat
un scénario redouté par le rock et par
les bourses qui sont passés dans le
rouge un moment cela dit ty colo est ce
qu'il est aigri l'eau est un comédien
qui s'est insurgé contre la classe
politique italienne mais contre
l'austérité et veut faire un référendum
sur l'euro un italien sur quatre a voté
pour son mouvement de protestation alors
nous sommes avec josé pays n'a pas terni
si vous êtes la correspondante de la
télévision italienne rai ici à bruxelles
alors on l'a vu sur les images beppe
grillo c'est la misère qui ne fait plus
rire personne
il est en position d'arbitré que fat il
faire de ces élus donc il a dit qu'il va
changer la conception des alliances
comme on la bio jusqu'ici et
et probablement ils cherchent de faire
des alliances mets et réforme sur
réforme donc pas le lien ce stade stable
pour un gouvernement mais quelque chose
pour changer le système avec des lois
qui sont les lois qu'il a présentée dans
son programme il n'est pas très connu
cki beppe grillo c'est l'extrême gauche
et l'extrême droite
donc c'est un mouvement qui s'est très
mélangées mais il faut comprendre que le
mouvement est né dans l'est dans les
ruelles et avec les institutions d'aidé
d'atteindre il est aussi et sur la web
donc c'est à dire sur twitter c'est à
dire sur le blog et c'est à dire mais on
a surtout je pense
dans ce groupe on a quelque chose de
très fort que les italiens veut dire à
la politique
est-ce que ce résultat c'est pas un
rejet de la politique de rigueur
d'austérité avec l'austérité mais contre
la caste est ce que la banque d'italie
on appelle la casta c'est à dire les
tous les députés tous les
et tous les gens qui sont des
privilégiés parce qu'il a eu beaucoup de
corruption en italie dans toutes les
parties et il n'y a pas été capable dé
changer le système et des données en
signal fort aux pays qui l'ont vraiment
la volonté de changer
et alors les gens ont dit moi je suis
tout le monde est en crise j'ai perdu le
travail
mon salaire est bloqué et ma fille qui
cette petite elle a perdu son petit
travail et c'est tout à cause de la
crise de la sortie européenne de la
crise et que c'est la sortie de
l'austérité et ils ont encore la fin de
la casta les privilégiés ils ont encore
fait des dépenses force des choses et là
ça a été en votes contre contre les
députés et contre la haine contre le
parlement en général et contre la sortie
européen
la sortie de la crise en europe et à
cette année contre l'austérité
vous disiez c'est une gifle à l'europe
les hommes de l'europe mario monti a
fait 10 % naturellement c'est ça mais
vous ne pouvez pas oublier que au mois
de décembre les gens paient en paient
limo limoux c'est à dire c'est une
taxation sur la propriété que c'est très
grande plage et les gens qu'ils ont
vraiment plus d'argent à cause de la
crise ils ont fait la taxation à deux
mois après les limouxins sont allés à
voter et donc ils ont voté contre
qui a imposé une taxation qui a vraiment
mis à peu posé beaucoup de problèmes aux
gens normale est du pays
parce que la récession en italie c'est
un contrefort et il va donner j'ai passé
moment et c'est là défi du du
gouvernement donner un signal très fort
qu'il va changer les choses c'est ça
l'italie c'est la troisième économie de
la zone euro ces deux mille milliards de
dettes on peut pas en rester là
qu'est ce qui va se passer oui
naturellement on peut pas rester là
et je pense que les partis démocratiques
qui a été le premier de toute façon ce
au sénat à la chambre des députés mais
qu'on sénat il n'y a pas la majorité non
pour pour pour faire un gouvernement et
donc je crois qu'il voix teintée
d'attenté des différents gouvernements
sur des petites réformes des petites
choses et après on sait jamais si on va
inventer une autre fois aussi va
continuer avec justement comment vous
voyez l'avenir est ce qu'il va y avoir
une oeuvre nouvelle élection dray c'est
possible c'est que beaucoup c'est dans
les mains des gardiens napolitaine et
c'est le président de la république
merci giuseppina appartient certes pas
de paternité alors on l'a dit donc les
élections italienne c'était une gifle à
l'europe
il y a aussi cette montée de
l'euroscepticisme en grande bretagne rim
benameur et elle est à la rencontre des
membres de l'ue you keep le parti
eurosceptique anglais c'est 20 % des
suffrages aux élections locales
reportage vos gosses et jack soudeuse
étudiant londonien
ils font partie des ions guînes
dépendance et les jeunes du you keep le
parti eurosceptique anglais c'est
toujours une cravate grise au mont
violette ce sont les couleurs de
l'équipe
je n'aimerais pas qu'on prenne soin
travailliste aujourd'hui il rencontre
edward membre du parti conservateur pour
débattre de leurs idées
donc vous concentrer surtout sur la
croissance en grande-bretagne
we you keep étant parquet qu'il veut de
l'europe une europe basée uniquement sur
le commerce
si nous quittons l'union les pays ne
vont pas arrêter d'échanger avec nous
ils ont besoin de ce business et les
deux étudiants ont de bonnes raisons d'y
croire
créée en 93 en plein débat sur le traité
de maastricht
le united kingdom independence party
will you keep est en passe de devenir la
troisième force politique du pays
j'étais intéressé par un you keep depuis
2009 quand il n'était qu'un petit parti
eurosceptique
puis j'ai regardé leur autre idée il y a
de bonnes propositions sur l'éducation
la santé les impôts quand équipe a
dépassé les 10%
j'ai décidé de rejoindre le parti et à
chaque élection les chiffres montrent
direction eastleigh à 1h20 de londres
tous les regards sont braqués vers cette
petite ville une élection législative
partielle si rejouer local jean paul you
keep d'occuper le terrain d'un nous
n'avons pas besoin de l'europe
nous n'en avons pas besoin ça nous coûte
50 millions de livres par jour
ces gens sont assis à bruxelles aidé de
tous pour nous et en plus ils vivent
comme des princes des arguments anti
europe repris par la candidate locale
dyan james
elle a rejoint you keep il ya seulement
deux ans ses chevaux de bataille plus de
réglementations sur l'immigration et la
tenue d'un référendum pour sortir de
l'union
oui on est le seul parti à répondre à la
demande populaire et avoir enfin le
choix
les seuls plus maintenant l'idée
désormais reprises par le premier
ministre en personne david cameron
mais pour la candidate de you keep c'est
un argument électoraliste de cameron
n'est pas honnête il dit vous pouvez
avoir un référendum en 2010 7 6 6 et 6
et encore si quatre grands chi ce n'est
pas une promesse ni un engagement c'est
une récupération
l'idée du référendum gagne de plus en
plus de terrain dans la classe politique
et le people splash y est pour beaucoup
ce lobby regroupe des pro et des anti
européens
leur objectif commun donner enfin la
parole au peuple anglais qui n'a pas été
consultée depuis 40 ans les gens pensent
que l'union européenne doit être plus
démocratique
de leur côté ceux qui veulent quitter
l'europe pense que le moment est venu
pour eux l'europe est une institution
dépassée qui décline sur le plan
économique
l'angleterre doit se tourner vers le
reste du monde
déjà 130 mille signatures pour leur
pétition en ligne dont une centaine de
députés britanniques parmi eux
jim fitzpatrick contrairement à la
majorité des signataires lui et
pro-européen j'ai signé la pétition car
je veux que la grande bretagne reste un
membre fort de l'union européenne et si
les britanniques peuvent s'exprimer il
voterait majoritairement pour rester
nous n'avons rien à craindre d'un
référendum si nous pouvons régler la
question pour une génération allons-y
n'ayant pas peur faisons le face à
l'europe
les britanniques sont pragmatiques si la
crise économique s'aggrave
l'euroscepticisme risque de gagner du
terrain selon les derniers sondages 60 %
des anglais sont désormais pour une
sortie de l'union européenne un
reportage signé rim benameur alors nous
sommes avec graham watson bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen vous
êtes britannique
vous êtes également ico c'est vous êtes
le président du parti des démocrates et
des libéraux un parti européen on va
dire vous êtes grosso modo centriste ici
en tout cas au parlement à bruxelles
et enfin vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères est
ce que voit titre personnel vous êtes
pour la tenue d'un référendum en
grande-bretagne
non je suis contre la tenue d'un
référendum
le sens que ça endommagent les
possibilités d investissement dans
l'économie britannique sur lesquels nous
dépendons cette idée ce nombre de postes
de travail donc sa vérité et je suis
contraint vers un homme sur un sujet où
personne ne sait vraiment pas quels sont
les enjeux
mais quand je ne serai pas combien
référendum sur un nouveau traité par
exemple mon parti était en faveur d'un
référendum en grande-bretagne sur le
traité de lisbonne a par exemple
mais quand on sait que les britanniques
n'ont pas été consultés sur l'europe
depuis très longtemps
est ce que finalement ce serait pas un
principe de base de la démocratie que de
leur demander ce qu'ils veulent
non ce n'est pas la démocratie c'est
quoi la démocratie directe ce sont les
référendums mais souvent les réponses ne
sont pas des réponses à des questions
posées sur les réponses à les personnes
qui posent des questions vous avez un
histoire en france des référendums sur
les traités européens
c'est une histoire malheureuse dirais
même les fonctions du nombre
nous nous ne l'avons pas fait
je pense que peut-être la démocratie
requiert d'ici quelques ans et une
consultation du public britannique sur
le sujet de l'europe car ce sujet est
redevenu très très très controverse
si vous posez la question aux gens quels
sont les plus chaudes les plus
importants ils n'hésitent pas l'europe
plus important se sait c'est l'emploi
c'est la santé c'est l'éducation et les
transports
mais quand même le sujet de l'europe
c'est quelque chose qui qui qui qui qui
qui qui nous trouble quand on voit son
un sondage par exemple dit que 60 % des
britanniques veulent maintenant quitté
l'union européenne
or il ya certaines de sondage qui dit 60
il ya certains qui disent 60 en faveur
les sondages s'est pas vraiment
à une bonne mesure juste je pense et si
on faisait une campagne dans un
référendum quitté au reste et la
majorité cendrillon faire d'autres
restèrent penser qu'il ya une majorité
des britanniques aujourd'hui parce
qu'encore une fois nous l'image qu'on a
de l'extérieur de ce pays c'est que
finalement les britanniques en ont assez
david cameron l'a dit dans son dans son
discours is il ne voit que les côtés
négatifs un petit peu ce que disait ce
monsieur c'est à dire bruxelles ça coûte
cher ça fait d'énormes inutile et c'est
donc ce que vous dites c'est que non en
fait c'est pas ça on peut toujours
critiquer l'europe mais les gens ne
savent pas nous sommes les moins bien en
informer de toutes les européens sur ce
qu'est l'europe ce qu'elle fait comment
elle fonctionne mais ce que nous voyons
ce que vous voyez en france on va dose
et autres pc et un nouveau nationalisme
le parti indépendantiste c'est comme le
front national en france c'est un parti
anti immigration
c'est un parti anti coopération
internationale or les grands défis
mondiaux d'aujourd'hui requièrent cette
coopération internationale donc il faut
que la classe politique se justifie au
ce qu'elle fait dans la construction de
l'europe
alors on a vu dans le reportage tout à
l'heure une candidate aux élections
locales est là une question pour vous et
ensuite on vous retrouve qu'est ce que
c'est les husky fication pour rester
encore pour continuer d'être une membre
de la communauté européenne
parce que c'est très difficile pour la
population du de comprendre pourquoi
moment la question en direct je suis
très heureux d'abord qu'elle parle le
français malheureusement il ya très peu
de mes compatriotes surtout de la
génération succès dante qui parle
français comme ça mais est ce qu'il ya
une justification
absolument comment je justifie non
seulement notre économie 3,0 3,5
millions de postes de travail mais aussi
notre sécurité la coopération policière
qui existe entre la grande bretagne et
la france qui nous a permis par exemple
de trouver cet instituteur qui a pris
une fille de 15 ans et qui qui qui est
allé en france de la retrouver que nous
on fait avec l'aide de la police
française à l'europe c'est pas possible
ça sent la robe c'est pas possible il
faudra toute une série d'accords
bilatéraux
on ne fait plus ça on fait l'europe
ensemble 1,27 jeu bientôt à 28
et ça marche en réalité très très bien
sans nous coûtait trop cher
la dégradation de la note vous avez
perdu jeudi vous mais je dois dire nous
aussi puisque les français c'est la même
chose de ce fameux triple a est ce que
en grande bretagne qu'est ce que c'est
on attribue la cause de cette
dégradation à la mauvaise santé de
l'économie de la zone euro en général on
literie en la tribu à la mauvaise
position de la zone euro mais on n'a pas
à raison de le faire
on doit la tribu et à la mauvaise
position de l'économie de la grande
bretagne parce que malheureusement les
politiques que nous avons introduit pour
essayer de résoudre cette crise
économique n'ont pas très bien
fonctionné
alors on a quand même le sentiment je
reviens petit peu sur ces aspects
démocratique et pas uniquement
d'ailleurs sur la sur la grande bretagne
que les européens on voit un certain
nombre de messages répétés alors vous
avez parlé du référendum de 2005
on a parlé tout à l'heure des élections
en italie peut-être ce référendum chez
vous on a le sentiment à chaque fois
comme ça que les peuples européens
envoient des messages et qu'ici à
bruxelles on les entend par est ce que
vous êtes quand même d'accord et c'est
ce qu'il faudrait il faudrait pas
écouter un petit peu les peuples
d'europe nous les à nous les entendons
nous les écoutons nous avons chacun de
nous nos circonscriptions dans nos pays
respectifs
le problème c'est que nous nous savons
comment répondre sans dire aux gens
franchement si on n'avait pas de
l'europe ce serait la catastrophe totale
on ne peut pas imaginer où c'est
difficile d'imaginer un europe des
tribus comme on l'avait dans le siècle
précédent où on faisait la guerre tous
les 30 ans or si on veut éviter ça il
faut construire l'europe lui construire
dans une façon et être acceptable pour
nos concitoyens
ça c'est plus difficile et le faire
quand nous souffrons tous du nez crise
économique de la demande
c'est encore plus difficile donc nous
allons à mon avis subir une dizaine
d'années de difficultés politiques avec
des nationalismes avec des extrémismes
et il faut que les gens qui croient en
la démocratie
les gens des parties mainstream se
mettent ensemble
si vous dites c'est soit les extrémismes
soit l'europe il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas de chemin intermédiaire
je ne vois pas en vue des grands défis
de ce monde
une population en croissance rapide et
une migration plus forte que jamais en
vue du défi du changement de timmins et
de la sécurité énergétique en vue du
défi de la criminalité organisée de
d'une économie de plus en plus
mondialisé on n'a pas de possibilité
sans se mettre ensemble à 500 millions
d'européens
pour faire face à tous ces défis merci
beaucoup on va voir effectivement si les
peuples européens sont persuadés
convaincu par ce que vous dites merci g
watson d'avoir accepté notre invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine et d'ici
là bonne suite de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires